every morning evgenya burkiewicz takes a
few minutes
she's holding a photo of her son maxime
she hasn't had any sign of life from him
since he was taken prisoner by the
russian military two months earlier
she's terrified he's being tortured or
that he's no longer alive
i sit and cry while my husband's still
asleep
when he gets up i wash my face
and
invited us in to hear about their son
maxim budkiewicz volunteered for
military service
for years he'd worked as a ukrainian
journalist and stood up for refugees and
human rights
when russia invaded ukraine they tell us
maksim decided to fight for his country
he's a pacifist and an anti-militarist
has been all his life
if we'd been younger we'd have joined
two but were too old
maxim's parents only found out he'd been
taken prisoner from a video shown on
russian state media
it showed their son being interrogated
in a cellar somewhere
i saw my only child in thought this
can't be true
over the following weeks social media
channels close to the kremlin labeled
maxim a nazi an ultra nationalist and
even a british spy over and over again
simply because in 2003 he worked as a
producer for the bbc
his parents went to the ukrainian
military ukraine security service and
aid organizations but no one could tell
them anything
my biggest worry is that they won't
treat our son as a pow but as a criminal
that's the way they've been doing with
many others
i'm worried that they'll put him on
trial using all these lies and trumped
up evidence
according to ukraine's security service
over 7000 ukrainians have now been taken
as prisoners of war by russian forces
the security service is collecting as
much information as possible but its
work is highly confidential so it turned
down our interview requests
however an attorney representing 50
families of pows was prepared to talk to
us
vladislav ignativ works closely with the
security service trying to bring the
pows back home
he thinks russia will be accusing more
and more ukrainian soldiers of being
nazis or committing other invented
crimes
i think this is uh this is done mostly
for the political purposes
when you create
such and you know importance of the
person like he's a great nazis you know
you may use it to
in in their political you know trait
maxim's parents are determined not to
let that happen
they have filed an emergency appeal with
the european court of human rights
hoping it will put pressure on russia to
allow international organizations access
to their son
we're doing this so we can find out how
maxime is doing we really have just one
goal
that maxime and his comrades be set free
until then evgenya and alexander
buchkevich are trying to remain strong
and fight back the panic and fear they
feel for their son